-So your father was
in the theater as well.
He was an actor,
director, producer.
And he directed
you and your siblings, yes?
-Yes.
-What was that like?
How was he as a director?
-Well, he was high energy.
He used to use a kitchen timer
to make sure that the actors
got the scene over
before it went off.
Now, that was kind of his style.
-Not a lot of long pauses.
-The man was amazing.
He produced and -- He produced
all of Shakespeare's plays
and directed many of them,
and we were a theater family.
I was on stage at age 2.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Playing one of Nora's children
in "Doll's House."
I don't remember
anything about it,
but I'm told I was very good.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it was a big deal
when I finally had lines.
-Oh, yeah, I imagine.
-I was about 7 years old.
-And then you had the chance
to direct your father.
-Yeah.
-And what was he like
as an actor?
Did he take direction well?
-He was, I would say, fustian.
-Okay.
-He was like an old-time
Shakespeare actor.
I sort of had to calm him down
a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
But he was fantastic.
You know, his -- Shakespeare
productions, when I was a kid,
were done on a unit stage
outdoors in the summertime
with huge crowds
and no amplification.
-Oh, wow.
-So I figured he was -- he was
entitled to that grand style.
-Of course.
And the audience was probably
very happy
that he entitled them with it.
-Yeah. They could --
They could hear him.
-You did the show. You've been
doing it for about 10 years.
You've taken it on the road.
And was it North Carolina
where you had a moment --
another moment where you had
to interact with the audience?
-Where did you find out
about all these?
-We do -- We do our digging.
We do our digging.
-No, I -- again,
"Stories by Heart"
in Greensboro, North Carolina,
I came out and talked to the
audience, chatted with them
for about five minutes then
finally sat down to begin
the sort of body of the work,
and I looked down,
and my fly was open.
[ Laughter ]
And there, again, I had two
hours to go,
and I looked at the crowd,
and I stood up and said,
"I'm so sorry.
Did anybody notice that my fly
has been open all this time?"
And a couple of them
raised their hand.
[ Laughter ]
And I said,
"Why didn't you tell me?
I am so embarrassed."
They loved it.
It was the best
the show ever went.
In fact, there were people who
thought it was part of the show.
[ Laughter ]
-You have too much integrity
for that.
You would never fake a fly down.
-Actually,
I've thought about it.
-It's always so great
to see you.